have you tried to get a rock star from
point A to point B neither have I but
apparently it's really hard get him to
the Greek yeah as a title but I said it
like a sentence
okay so Jonah Hill is a music label PR
intern guy in the movie and he needs to
get rock legend all the snow from London
to LA for an anniversary concert and he
has about two days to do it
easy right and all sorts of ridiculous
happens in between there's kind of
like planes trains and automobiles with
a lot of crudeness drugs and rocks died
and I won't lie I laughed a lot during
this movie I ultimately liked most of
the comedies that come out this year and
I like to laugh who doesn't and for
the most part this movie had it
sometimes it kind of didn't but for the
most part it did what I really liked
about this movie is that musically it
pokes fun at a lot of the that
becomes popular I mean Laffy Taffy are
you serious and it totally jab did a lot
of the musical train wrecks that
become popular when a movie can laugh at
the rich and famous that's always funny
Jonah Hill and Russell Brand worked
really well in this movie I mean their
characters just worked well together
probably because they were absolutely
complete opposites although Russell
Brand are Aldus know we got to be a
little too much sometimes but he's
a rock star he's supposed to be this
movie does seem about 15 minutes too
long it might be because they cover a
lot of ground in an hour and 50 minutes
I mean sometimes the segment's look like
a bunch of short segments stapled
together made for a lot of laughs it's a
bit of a road trip with planes in Vegas
and fun but there's this segment near
the end of the movie hi Jonah Hills
apartment it just felt kind of awkward
and unnecessary yeah I just felt awkward
unfunny and really forced almost like
they were like hey this movie's only an
hour and 40 minutes long I was Penn in
10 minutes say yeah I mean from my money
if he went from a slump a depression to
the roof and cut that whole segment out
in between life it'd be good but he's
just one scene I mean ultimately it's
like one twentieth of the movie so I'm
not gonna hold on to it too much so the
characters worked really well together
it was funny as although a bit long
and it tried to have some deeper meaning
of life message buried underneath all
the heroin and pot scenarios and so I'd
say go see it this weekend because like
knocked up if you wait till next weekend
to see it it'll be overhyped as
it'll just disappoint you if you see it
this weekend should be good and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more than click here to see my
other videos that I've made just for you
because I care
[Music]